you
well I think the the two questions but a
bioethicists asked to ask in the
abortion debate are one is it a question
of whether life when life begins or is
it a question of either permitting or
prohibiting abortion like the
independence phenomenon if you're
interested in the question of when life
begins then the motivation for the
pregnancy should be utterly irrelevant
to your decision-making if you believe
that a fetus attains a person that had
passed a certain age even if that fetus
is the product of rape or incest it
wouldn't make sense to allow someone to
terminate a pregnancy if you believe
that fetuses personhood in contrast
there are other reasons one might oppose
abortion rights independent of when the
fetus begins when the life begins one
might say I acknowledge that fetuses
aren't human beings life doesn't begin
until birth but if we ban abortion we
reduce the likelihood of teenage
pregnancy sexually transmitted disease
we can reverse the social and social
revolution of 1960s which many people do
advocate and do believe and from their
point of view whether or not the fetus
is a human being is an irrelevant
question I think as a society today and
bio emphasis particularly have largely
focused on the question of when life
begins I am fairly radical in my views
in my sense but I would permit abortion
up to the point of birth I think that
the arbitrary distinction that fetuses
acquire personhood at a certain point
it's simply too big an area and too
uncertain premise to enforce in law the
example I always use and it's somewhat
trivial but at the same time evinces the
question well I think is small children
making jello if you have a small child
making jello they put the colored water
in the refrigerator they run away they
come back 30 seconds later they put
their finger in the jello is it colored
water as the jello and they do this over
and over again until suddenly a
miraculously it becomes jello the
development of a fetus operates the same
way birth is an easy guideline the truth
is since I believe it's in thien's and
cogging cognition or consciousness
define life there probably are infants
in the first few days of life who don't
really have cognition who don't have
distance sentience but for a practical
realistic way of running the world we
couldn't live in a world where we used
in iseman or allowed in that aside that
being said I would also add
to buy our episode I have written
extensively on treating infanticide and
particularly mothers with postpartum
depression and postpartum psychosis as
distinct from other murderers and other
criminals I think we should grant great
latitude to women who kill or euthanized
their infants at birth and treat them
with with kindness to someone suffering
from an illness
oh I think the answer to that is fairly
simple the ancient Romans for example
didn't view birth as a cut-off point
they had a certain number of days and
buried where in Rome you were before a
child gainful personhood the ancient
Spartan certainly didn't view infants at
birth as having human human capacity or
human value we have a very hard time
distinguishing whether a child once born
is three days old or seven days old or
two months old and you don't want to
have a system that has Courts engaged in
the process figuring out exactly how
many days old the baby was and having
people's lives a mere prospect of going
free or spending time in jail dependent
on exactly how many days they were post
birth so my actual philosophical drawing
line would be far past birth in terms of
days or weeks but there's no practical
way to implement that you could easily
figure out how many days before birth or
how many trimesters how many weeks a
fetus was but ultrasound but there's no
point along that parameter where I would
feel that a child or an fetus has enough
capacity enough sentience to be
considered a human being